Welcome! In this video, we'll build a complete REST API
from scratch using Node.js and Express.
By the end, you'll understand how to set up an Express server,
create API endpoints, and deploy your API.
Let's get started! First, make sure you have Node.js 16 or higher
installed on your computer.
Open your terminal and check your Node.js version
with the command: node --version
Great! Now let's create our project directory.
Type: mkdir my-rest-api
Then navigate into it: cd my-rest-api
Initialize npm in the project: npm init -y
Now let's install Express, which is the framework
we'll use to build our API.
Type: npm install express cors
We're also installing CORS to handle cross-origin requests.
This installation takes about 10 seconds.
Perfect! Now let's create our server file.
Create a file called server.js
And open it in your code editor.
Now, let's write the code to create an Express server.
Type the following code:
const express = require('express');
const cors = require('cors');
const app = express();
const PORT = 3000;
Next, we add middleware:
app.use(cors());
app.use(express.json());
Finally, we start the server:
app.listen(PORT, () => {
console.log(`Server running on port $`);
});
Here's what's happening:
1. We import Express and CORS libraries
2. We create an app instance
3. We add middleware to handle JSON and cross-origin requests
4. We start the server on port 3000
Now let's add our first API endpoint.
Add this code before app.listen():
app.get('/', (req, res) => {
res.json();
});
This endpoint:
- Uses the GET HTTP method
- Responds to requests to the root path '/'
- Returns a JSON response with a welcome message
Let's test it. In the terminal, type:
npm start
Or if you installed nodemon for auto-reload:
nodemon server.js
Great! The server is running on port 3000.
Now let's test the endpoint using Postman.
Create a GET request to http://localhost:3000/
Click Send.
Excellent! Our first endpoint is working.
We got the welcome message in JSON format.
Now let's create more endpoints to make this a real API.
Let's create a simple in-memory database with some users.
Add this code before your routes:
let users = [
,
];
Now let's add our first user endpoint.
This will GET all users:
app.get('/api/users', (req, res) => {
res.json(users);
});
Let's add another endpoint to get a specific user by ID:
app.get('/api/users/:id', (req, res) => {
const user = users.find(u =>
u.id === parseInt(req.params.id)
);
if (!user) {
return res.status(404).json();
}
res.json(user);
});
The `:id` in the route is a parameter.
We access it with req.params.id
Now let's add a POST endpoint to create a new user:
app.post('/api/users', (req, res) => {
const  = req.body;
if (!name || !email) {
return res.status(400).json({
error: 'Name and email required'
});
}
const newUser = {
id: users.length + 1,
name,
email
};
users.push(newUser);
res.status(201).json(newUser);
});
Now let's restart the server and test these endpoints.
Press Ctrl+C to stop the server.
Then start it again: npm start
Now let's test the endpoints in Postman.
First, GET all users:
Make a GET request to http://localhost:3000/api/users
Click Send.
Great! We got both users in the response.
Now let's get a specific user. Change the URL to:
http://localhost:3000/api/users/1
Click Send.
Perfect! We got Alice's data.
Now let's create a new user using POST.
Change the method to POST
The URL stays: http://localhost:3000/api/users
Click the Body tab, select "raw", and change to JSON.
Type the following JSON:
{
"name": "Charlie",
"email": "charlie@example.com"
}
Click Send.
Excellent! We successfully created a new user.
We've successfully:
- Retrieved all users
- Retrieved a specific user
- Created a new user
This is the core of a REST API!
Now let's add proper error handling.
A good API needs to handle errors gracefully.
Add this error handling middleware at the end of your code,
before app.listen():
app.use((err, req, res, next) => {
console.error(err);
res.status(500).json({
error: 'Internal server error'
});
Also add a 404 handler for non-existent routes:
app.use((req, res) => {
res.status(404).json({
error: 'Not found'
});
Restart the server and test it.
Try accessing a non-existent endpoint:
GET http://localhost:3000/api/invalid
Click Send.
Perfect! Our error handling is working.
We get a 404 error with a proper error message.
Now let's add environment variables for the port.
This is important for deployment.
Change this line:
const PORT = 3000;
To:
const PORT = process.env.PORT || 3000;
Now we can set the PORT environment variable,
and the app will use that. If not set, it defaults to 3000.
Great! We've built a complete REST API with:
- Express server setup
- GET and POST endpoints
- Error handling
- Environment variables
All in just 15 minutes!
Here are some next steps to improve your API:
1. Database: Use PostgreSQL instead of in-memory arrays
2. Authentication: Add JWT authentication
3. Validation: Use a library like Joi for request validation
4. Documentation: Create API documentation with Swagger
5. Deployment: Deploy to Heroku or AWS
6. Testing: Write automated tests
Check out the GitHub repository for the complete code.
All the links are in the description.
Thanks for watching! If you found this helpful:
- Like and subscribe for more tutorials
- Check out the linked repository for the full code
- Let me know what you'd like to see next in the comments
Good luck with your API development!
See you in the next video!